[Applauso]
Io sono un bancario di giorno è un
inventore di giochi da tavolo la notte
una sorta di Batman versione 2.0 ma con
alcune sostanziali differenze per
Innanzitutto non ho né un mantello e né
una maschera perché sono già tutto nero
e quindi questo mi consente di
risparmiare sugli accessori non ho una
Batmobile tutto quello che mi serve è
qualche foglio una forbice una matita e
un po' di colori per dare sfogo a quella
creatività che purtroppo rimanere pressa
durante il giorno la mia grotta di
Gotham City a volte il salotto altre
volte la cucina
cerco sempre di evitare il bagno anche
se alcuni lo considero un luogo di
meditazione e che di ispirazione
Purtroppo non ho un maggiordomo come
Alfred un consigliere che mi possa dare
una mano nel mio processo creativo però
ho tantissimi amici che si dimostrano
disponibili quando devo testare un mio
gioco nuovo e in qualità di supereroe
Oggi sono qui con una missione ben
precisa Voglio condividere con tutti voi
un messaggio in cui credo tantissimo
riscopriamo la bellezza e la magia di
giocare insieme
Quindi adesso giochiamo insieme
chiudete gli occhi Mi raccomando non
voglio nessuno che sbircia e ascoltate
attentamente le mie parole
immaginate di essere seduti su una sedia
e di fronte a voi c'è un tavolo con al
centro un solo dado state giocando con
altre persone
allungate la mano e afferrate il Dado e
stringetelo forte Mi raccomando rimanete
concentrati perché è arrivato il vostro
turno di gioco ora lanciate il dado sul
tavolo e focalizzate la vostra
attenzione sul numero che è uscito
potete riaprire gli occhi
alzi la mano Chi ha visualizzato il
numero uno
il due
Ok adesso il 3
il 4
bene il 5
multi e alla fine sei
fantastico
ha vinto il 6
ho scelto di fare questo gioco con voi
per tre motivi principali Beh
innanzitutto volevo settare la vostra
mente sul fantastico mondo dei giochi da
tavolo e poi perché giocare è il modo
migliore per presentarsi pensate a
quello che succede fra i bambini anche
quello più timido Quando gioca si sente
a suo agio e poi perché volevo
conoscervi meglio Ebbene sì Non so se lo
sapete ma il numero che avete scelto di
comunicarmi Racconta qualcosa di voi del
vostro carattere della vostra
personalità perché si sono storie
culture e credenze che associano ad ogni
numero un determinato significato ma io
oggi vi parlerò di un numero in
particolare che è il numero
4 questo numero è sempre stato un numero
ricco di significato nel corso della
storia è anche una certa correlazione
con il mondo dei giochi da tavolo
Pensiamo ad esempio al Quadrifoglio che
è un simbolo universalmente riconosciuto
come fortunato noi sappiamo quanto la
fortuna sia una componente importante
del mondo dei giochi Ma poi perché al 4
viene associato anche un concetto di
concretezza di stabilità e se noi
andiamo ad analizzare il termine gioco
da tavolo la parola tavolo non è stato
utilizzata casualmente nel linguaggio
dei segni Infatti il tavolo viene
associato
alla casa alla famiglia e al concetto di
stabilità stesso e guarda caso il tavolo
per essere stabile deve poggiare su
quattro punti perché vi ho raccontato
queste curiosità sul 4 e sui numeri in
generale perché alla base della maggior
parte dei giochi da tavolo ci sono i
numeri
e c'è la matematica il calcolo della
probabilità la frequenza la casualità le
combinazioni sono tutti elementi che
incidono sulle dinamiche di un gioco e
ne determinano la velocità di
svolgimento la durata e l'esperienza di
gioco in generale Se non si crea il
giusto mix quando si inventa un gioco
possono succedere delle cose molto
spiacevoli vi faccio un esempio se da
caso con i vostri amici e dopo una bella
pizza decidete di giocare ad un party
game uno di quei giochi perfetti quando
si è in tante persone inizia la partita
e dopo soli 10 minuti venite eliminati
come vi sentiresti soprattutto se quella
partita durasse per un'altra ora
una noia mortale e non ho dubbi che non
sarete certo voi ad alzare la mano per
giocare a quel gioco nella prossima
serata tra amici magari non vi è mai
capitato ma sono certo che a molti di
voi sia capitato di giocare di più
durante il lockdown
perché in quel periodo avevamo bisogno
di giocare insieme e giocare di più e
quindi magari abbiamo recuperato delle
vecchie scatole dei giochi dalle cantine
dalle soffitte oppure rovistando in
fondo gli armadi perché in quel periodo
avevamo proprio bisogno di creare un po'
di leggerezza in quelle lunghe giornate
obbligati a stare in casa Voi ve li
ricordate i dpcm
chi non se le ricorda pensate nel
novembre del 2020 c'è stato un decreto
ministeriale che ha introdotto i giochi
e i giocattoli nella categoria dei beni
essenziali beni di prima necessità avete
capito bene il governo ha formalizzato
il fatto che giocare è di vitale
importanza così come alimentarsi
e la storia ci racconta in tanti modi
che giocare è un bisogno primordiale
dell'uomo e nello specifico i giochi da
tavolo hanno rivestito un ruolo cruciale
nella vita delle persone
migliaia di anni fa gli antichi egizi
Infatti giocavano già ad un gioco da
tavolo si chiamava senet che magari
qualcuno di voi ha già visto se ha
visitato il museo Egizio di Torino ed
era talmente importante giocarci che
questo gioco addirittura veniva messo
nella tomba del faraone insieme a tutti
gli altri oggetti della quotidianità per
affrontare il viaggio nell'aldilà
poi non avrei mai voluto essere nei
panni dell'aristocratico egiziano che
batteva il faraone Ma questo è un
piccolo dettaglio oppure pensiamo agli
antichi romani che già all'epoca
giocavano ad un gioco uno contro uno che
si basava sulla replica delle tecniche
militari e che si dice possa essere
l'antenato dei moderni scacchi che noi
sappiamo essere un gioco di strategia
anche se in realtà le rivendicazioni
sulla paternità di questo gioco sono
molteplici quindi i romani preparavano
le loro battaglie giocando ad un gioco
da tavolo pensate a quante competenze
attitudini qualità si possono imparare
giocando insieme
voi avete mai pensato a quante cose puoi
imparare un bambino solamente aspettando
il suo turno di gioco
Beh innanzitutto Impara a rispettare le
regole e a rispettare le altre persone
Ma nell'attesa il bambino stimola il
pensiero che mossa farò quando toccare a
me il prossimo giro quindi il bambino
impara a pianificare una strategia ma
anche a cambiarla perché magari il
giocatore di prima di lui farà una mossa
che li scombinerà i piani quindi il
bambino impara a trovare una soluzione
Impara anche a capire l'impatto delle
sue scelte e delle sue azioni verso le
altre persone e viceversa
Poi tra di noi ci possiamo anche dire
che aspettare un po' troppo Durante il
turno degli altri a volte un po' palloso
soprattutto quando abbiamo a che fare
con dei giocatori un po' lenti come ad
esempio mia mamma
quando gioco a carte con lei sta lì
concentrato sul mazzo e gira e rigira si
concentra talmente tanto che a volte
vedo proprio il fucile dalle orecchie
allora A quel punto mi viene spontaneo
facciamo notte e quella pressione serve
sempre perché lei Velocizza il turno
scarta poi alza la testa
e mi lancia uno sguardo che è un mix tra
il faraone che ha perso la partita e il
comandante romano che sta per sferrare
un attacco mortale sul campo di
battaglia
perché abbiamo fatto questo piccolo
Viaggio nel tempo del mondo dei giochi
per comprendere meglio i cambiamenti che
stiamo vivendo oggi
Come si sono evolute le società e le
culture Infatti è cambiato anche il
concetto di gioco stesso
Pensiamo ad esempio a quello che è
successo negli ultimi 15 anni Con
l'avvento delle App sui nostri
smartphone è diventato talmente facile
scaricare una miriade di giochi sui
nostri telefonini che noi giochiamo
tantissimo e lo facciamo ovunque sul
treno in metropolitana nella sala
d'attesa prima di entrare dal dottore
oppure belli spaparanzati sul divano
dopo una lunga giornata di lavoro ma
qual è la grande differenza rispetto
agli antichi egizi ai Romani o
semplicemente ai nostri nonni
noi giochiamo di più questo è innegabile
ma lo facciamo da soli
ecco qual è la grande differenza
rispetto al passato Ecco perché Oggi più
che mai dobbiamo riscoprire la magia e
la bellezza di giocare insieme
qualche settimana fa
mentre portavo in giro i miei due
cagnolini sono passato di fianco ad un
Giardinetto pubblico e ho visto quattro
ragazzini seduti sulla panchina uno
accanto all'altro ciascuno intento a
giocare con il proprio cellulare
sono stato lì parecchi minuti Il tempo
di fare il solito giro dell'isolato ma
quando sono tornato
e nulla era cambiato
ci dicono che viviamo in un'epoca di
condivisione Ma siamo sicuri che sia
così
siamo certi che non sia esattamente il
contrario
un'epoca caratterizzata dall'isolamento
e da barriere che si creano nelle
relazioni vuole dentro le mura delle
nostre case
vedete
all'inizio del mio Talk mi sono
paragonato a Batman
ma la realtà è che io non ho nulla a che
vedere con i supereroi
sono solo un genitore
un padre che ha commesso degli errori
dopo tutto nessuno ci fornisce un
libretto delle istruzioni
che ci dica Come interpretare questo
ruolo
e io non sono stato in grado di creare
equilibrio
tra il tempo che mio figlio passava
online con la tecnologia
e tutto il resto
e questo purtroppo ho avuto delle
conseguenze
calo dell'attenzione
mal di testa ricorrente
disturbi del sonno
fino ad arrivare ad una scarsa
padronanza delle emozioni
mio figlio
quando guardo un film aveva una scena
triste manda avanti
non vuole emozionarsi
e noi sappiamo che le emozioni sono
quanto di più bello ci possa regalare la
vita
le ricerche scientifiche in questo campo
sono ancora in una fase di elaborazione
non c'è abbastanza materiale per
arrivare ad una conclusione quindi
nessuno sa veramente quali saranno le
conseguenze che l'eccessivo utilizzo
della tecnologia avrà sui nostri bambini
su di noi o sulla società del futuro
Ma io non potevo mica aspettare i dati
della ricerca
c'è stato un momento della mia vita in
cui mi sono detto Devo fare qualcosa
e i giochi da tavolo sono stati i miei
grandi alleati li ho introdotti sempre
di più nella mia famiglia per attirare
l'attenzione di mio figlio Riccardo che
fra poco compirà 11 anni verso un tipo
di intrattenimento alternativo e le cose
sono migliorate moltissimo
e forse sì
la verità
è che volevo essere il supereroe
di mio figlio
Per questo ho iniziato ad inventarmi
io non ho una ricetta per la felicità
o per Come creare leggerezza all'interno
delle nostre famiglie ma Di una cosa
sono certo
passare più tempo con i nostri figli con
i nostri cari con i nostri amici
giocando insieme
è uno dei regali più belli
che ci possiamo fare
Questo è il nostro Dado
a chi tocca tirare
Buona fortuna
[Musica]
[Applauso]